tras cuatro semanas de puertas cerradas
los restaurantes de la capital china
vuelven a abrir sus puertas a medida que
la situación mejora en el país beijing
también se dispone a relajar las
restricciones sobre las comidas en
sitios cerrados los servicios de
mensajería y las clases presenciales
pero se mantiene la precaución y se
mantendrán los controles frecuentes
hemos reducido el número de mesas en un
50% además de utilizar el armario de
desinfección desinfectar hemos aún más
nuestra vajilla en agua hirviendo
desinfectar hemos las sillas y otras
cosas después de que se vaya cada
cliente y desinfectar hemos el suelo
cada dos horas la política de 'cero kobe
de china ha tenido un coste social y
económico aplastante ahora el
levantamiento de las restricciones es
una medida bienvenida especialmente para
la industria de servicios este sector
fue el segundo más afectado con una
caída de más del 35 por ciento en abril
se espera que el consumo se recupere a
medida que los espacios públicos como
los centros comerciales vuelvan a abrir
sus puertas
esperamos que las ventas al pormenor se
multipliquen 30 veces a nuestro apoyo
financiero dijo el gobierno chino
anunció recientemente una nueva ronda de
vales y cupones a partir del viernes un
paquete de cupones por valor de unos 214
dólares al mes disponible al comprar
electrodomésticos de bajo consumo tiene
como objetivo impulsar la economía
rezagada y promover una energía más
limpia